j'ai
l'honneur au nom du Gouvernement de la
République de demander à l'Assemblée
nationale l'abolition de la peine de
mort en
France bonsoir il était 3h30 cet
après-midi quand le garde desess saau
Robert Badinter a donc prononcé cette
phrase qui rejoindra sans doute les
grands moments les grands débats des
élus du peuple qu'on soit pour ou contre
la peine de mort il est certain que ce
17 septembre 81 marquera une date voilà
près tr/ de que les députés ne s'étaient
saisis d'un projet de loi portant sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort c'était
le fameux débat de 1908 entre jores et
barè entre-etemps nombreux furent ceux à
bataillé pour supprimer la guillotine en
France à gauche et à droite et face à
une opinion hostile François mitteran
pendant la campagne il y a 6 mois avait
répété son hostilité à la peine capitale
et c'est d'ailleurs l'un des plus
farouches avocats de l'abolitionnisme
qu'il a placé au ministre à la justice
et qui se retrouvait donc cet après-midi
devant les députés je dis simplement
rappelant la phrase de jores puisquelle
évidence en vous sa parole n'est pas
éteinte la peine de mort est contraire à
ce que l'humanité depuis 2000 ans a
penser de plus haut et rêver de plus
noble
elle est contraire à la fois à l'esprit
du christianisme et à l'esprit de la
Révolution et nous savons bien
que certains vous diront qu'en votant
l'abolition vous
méconnaîtriez la démocratie parce que
vous méconnaîtriez l'opinion
publique il n'en est
rien le pays a élu une majorité de
gauche dans le programme de laquelle
figurait cette
disposition se faisant le pays en
connaissance de cause savait qu'il
approuvait un programme
législatif dans lequel se trouvait
inscrit au premier rang des obligations
morales l'abolition de la peine de mort
à cet instant lorsque vous la voterez
c'est ce pacte
solennel celui qui lit l'élu au pays
celui qui fait que le premier devoir de
l'élu et le respect de l'engagement pris
avec ceux qui l'ont choisi c'est cette
démarche là de respect du suffrage
universel et de la démocratie qui sera
la vôtre Robert balinter a ensuite
écarté l'idée d'un référendum seant se
référent d'ailleurs au général de Gaulle
qui était hostile en la matière et puis
il a réfuté l'argument le plus utilisé
par les les partisans de la peine de
mort à savoir la peur peut dissuader les
criminels n'a
jamais jamais été
établi une corrélation quelconque
entre la présence ou l'absence de la
peine de mort dans une législation
pénale et la courbe de la criminalité
sanglante seul pour la peine de mort on
invente l'idée que la peur de la mort
retient l'homme dans ses passions
extrêmes ce n'est pas exact et puisque
vous avez prononcé tout à l'heure le nom
de deux condamnés à mort et de deux
exécutés je vous dirai pourquoi est-ce
que plus qu'aucun autre je sais qu'il
n'y a pas dans la peine de mort de
valeur dissuasive sachez bien que dans
la foule qui a tro créit au passage de
buffet et de bon temps autour du palais
de justice à mort buffet à mort bonemps
se trouvait un jeune homme qui
s'appelait Patrick Henry croyez-moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je l'ai appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive de la
peine de
mort garde d saau a demandé qu'il n'y
ait pas d'amendement à son texte pas de
restriction par exemple pas de peine de
substitution et puis il s'est adressé à
ceux qui trouvent que décidément dans ce
genre de cas de conscience on a trop
souvent tendance à oublierier les
victimes
la mort et la souffrance des
victimes ce terrible malheur la mort et
la souffrance des victimes pour le
partisan de la peine de
mort appelle comme une contrepartie
nécessaire
impérative une autre mort et une autre
souffrance à défaut disait un ministre
de de la justice récent l'angoisse et la
passion né dans la société par le crime
ne seraiit pas
apaisé cela s'appelle je crois le
sacrifice expiatoire ceux qui volulent
une justice qui tue ceuxlà sont animés
par une double conviction la première et
qu'il existe des hommes totalement
coupables c'est-à-dire des hommes
totalement responsables de leurs actes
et la
deuxième c'est qu'il peut y avoir une
justice sûre de son
infaillibilité au point de dire que
celui-là peut vivre et que celui-là doit
mourir et bien arriv à cet âge de ma vie
l'une et l'autre affirmation me
paraissent également
erronné aussi terrible aussi odieux que
soi leurs
actes il n'est point d'homme en cette
terre dont la culpabilité soit totale et
dont il faille pour toujours désespéré
totalement et quant à la justice aussi
prudente
soit-elle
aussi mesuré
angoissé que soi les femmes et les
hommes qui juge rien ne peut changer que
cette justice soit humaine et par
conséquent
faillible